bonjour à tous bienvenue sur la chaîne
parlementaire c'est l'heure de parlement
hebdo on va refaire l'actualité
politique et parlementaire 45 minutes
avec mes côtés kathia gilder
bonjourbonjour michael est la une cette
semaine à l'ump la nouvelle équipe se
met en place autour de nicolas sarkozy
question quels seront les rapports de
forces entre les différentes
sensibilités du mouvement quant aux
primaires elle ne serait plus à débat
selon le nouveau président de l'ump les
candidats ont tous défilé trop serré du
parti cette semaine et on parlera aussi
de la colère des patrons qui sont
descendus dans la rue pour protester
contre les mesures économiques les
concernant ils dénoncent notamment trop
de charges trop de talent c'est un conte
pénibilité inapplicable bras de fer est
engagé avec le gouvernement à
l'assemblée nationale a donné son feu
vert à la reconnaissance de l'état
palestinien la résolution socialiste a
été voté à une très large majorité mais
sans unanimité une majorité de députés
de droite s'y est opposé à ce texte pour
commenter cette semaine jérôme chartier
est avec nous bonjour député ump du val
d'oise proche de françois fillon l'ump
sont présents sans avenir
il en sera largement question tout à
l'heure mais d'abord c'est la tradition
que pensez-vous de jérôme chartier c'est
ce qu'on a demandé à certains de vos
collègues à l'assemblée écouter ce que
je n'aime pas en député cdh en politique
pardon c'est le sectarisme
jérôme chartier n'est pas quelqu'un de
sectaire quelqu'un qui aime les idées
qui aime le débat d'idées qui a une
réflexion est donc voilà quelqu'un pour
qui j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
on n'a pas choisi nécessairement les
mêmes chevaux mais c'est quelqu'un qui
fait un boulot remarquable
j'apprécie aussi les entretiens de
royaumont qu'il met sur pied depuis
plusieurs années qui démontre qu'on peut
être un politique bien attaché à son
présent mais aussi qui fait de la
prospective qui réunit à la fois des
intellectuels des hommes d'opinion des
femmes d'opinion et donc oui j'ai de
l'amitié et du respect pour jérôme
chartier et donc je vous souhaite une
bonne émission avec nous sommes engagés
on va toujours ma préférence et mon
admiration et jérôme est engagée avec
ses convictions je mette d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec clips sur certains points
mais il a de l'allant du sérieux et ils
seront pas aussi annuler
d'un secteur engagé fillonniste aussi ce
que vous avez vous arrivez à vous
détacher de cette image de fille liste
très proche de françois fillon
j'assume mon amitié avec françois et
puis mon engagement bien sûr c2c la fois
une amitié et je le redis mais il est
aussi une condition la conviction que
françois est l'homme de la situation
l'homme pour pour l'avenir de la france
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me sens
très bien dans ma peau comme on dit oui
à tant de compliments ça fait peut-être
un petit peu rougis oui mais on vit de
l'intérieur
mais c'est vrai je suis très frugale
châssis savons qu'il est sensible
surtout que j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour les personnes qui se sont exprimées
la caisse l'idée vous que certains
détestent le sectarisme
c'est le pire de la république les
sectarismes c'est la honte de la
république au revoir à la république
s'est passé ça peut pas être sectaire
c'est vraiment une conviction que
partagent tous une façon de vivre
ensemble une façon de partager de faire
grandir un ensemble une nation et c'est
forcément hors de tout temps le séisme
alors le parti c'est une chose si vous
voulez c'est la façon d'exprimer ses
convictions bien sûr mais au delà du
parti il ya toute la rhétorique et c'est
la capacité de dialogue avec la
république ce soit avec d'autres
formations partisanes que ce soit avec
n'importe quel individu qui à mon avis
fonde le principe même de nation on a
entendu un député seul à qui parler des
entretiens de royaumont expliquer ce que
c'est un petit peu plus tard à la fin de
cette émission mais c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose de très important pour
vous c'est à dire de rassembler
politiques et société civile pour qu'il
ya un mix de tout ça et finalement que
la parole soit libre oui je me suis très
engagé pour lancer ces entretiens il ya
plus de dix ans maintenant
et d'ailleurs je me suis mis un peu en
retrait cette année c'est à dire que je
ne préside plus les entretiens avec le
directeur pour une raison très simple
c'est que justement
je veux favoriser le dialogue inter
partisans interculturel inter sociale et
chaque année il ya une personnalité qui
président de la session annuelle des
entretiens et qui le bien rang de cette
facilité le dialogue entre malamine
promis on en parlera à la fin de la fin
de cette émission l'a dit les patrons
sont dans la rue et c'est tout de même
assez rare pour être souligné mais pas
trop et est dans la rue ils étaient
plusieurs milliers à manifester leur
colère
la pression fiscale et plus généralement
sur la politique économique du
gouvernement
écoutez quelques-unes de leurs
revendications on se rend compte que ce
ras-le-bol général c'est que tôt ou tard
il faut une prise de conscience quand on
est entrepreneur on prend des risques il
faut nous laisser faire
après il ya suffisamment d'instance pour
contrôler derrière mais laissez nous
entreprendre
laissez-nous et développer des
entreprises on a une vocation naturelle
à créer de l'emploi sur ce qu'il nous
faut de la visibilité
on n'arrête pas d'avoir des contraintes
supplémentaires des contraintes
administratives sociales fiscales
on a des marges qui continuent de
baisser
on a pas on a un carnet de commandes qui
n'arrêtent pas de baisser
malheureusement et malgré ça et bien
on n'arrête pas de nous contraindre là
on va mettre encore la pénibilité s'est
passé à tous les jours c'est la première
fois que je fais ça parce que je voulais
10 et marc celui là était bon qu'on
essaie de nous comprendre davantage et
de comprendre surtout c'est très
important que les petites et moyennes
entreprises sont très importantes dans
la vie économique du pays
sa réponse à une semaine d'initiative
ils n'en font pas trop les patrons n'ont
pas du tout au contraire je trouve que
c'est viable et là dans leurs actions et
soutient totalement je trouve ça très
grave lorsqu'on pense que les
entrepreneurs sont obligés de descendre
dans la rue pour se faire entendre
ça veut dire qu'il ya vraiment un
problème dans cette société française
les entrepreneurs les entrepreneurs
c'est le coeur de la formation de ce que
l'on appelle la valeur ajoutée
c'est-à-dire la création de richesses en
france ce sont les entrepreneurs qui l'a
créé avec tous les salariés qui
participent au développement des projets
d'entreprises se dire que les
entrepreneurs sont obligés de descendre
dans la rue pour se faire entendre
aujourd'hui c'est que vraiment quelque
chose tourne mal en france entre les
patrons et le gouvernement est ce que
vos impressions que justement de nos
gouvernements soufflé le chaud et le
froid
je trouve surtout que le gouvernement
avait la capacité d'engager un dialogue
avec les entrepreneurs qu'ils étaient
prêts à le faire il y a quelques mois de
cela et qu'il a raté le coche qui a raté
le coche et surtout la force de mentir
aux patrons comme le gouvernement a
nation aujourd'hui on se retrouve devant
une situation qui est inextricable qui
fait que les patrons sont obligés de
manifester
enfin on n'a jamais vu ça ça veut bien
dire qu'on est arrivé au bout du bout du
bout et que le gouvernement doit trouver
les conditions pour rendre le dialogue
mais surtout doit arrêter le caricaturer
de stigmatiser j'ai entendu michel sapin
il y a quelques jours parler de pierre
gattaz dans des termes qui sont
lamentables comment est-ce qu'on peut
fustiger quelqu'un qui est
fils d'entrepreneur entrepreneur lui
même qui est une entreprise française à
la tête d'une entreprise française qui
produit en france comment peut-on
arriver à critiquer de la sorte a
stigmatisé de la sorte quelqu'un qui
produit de la valeur en france c'est
vrai et c'est mardi le gouvernement et
autres la relation entre pia xiii
gouvernement c'est un petit peu tendu
après emmanuel macron c'est le premier
ministe manuel valls qui sont au medef
les déclarations sont donc plutôt que
dure contre dénoncé les provocations des
dirigeants du patronat c'est mounir
soucis qui nous expliquent cela est
évidemment au regret avec vous pour en
discuter
le gouvernement commence à perdre
patience face au medef
après avoir consenti 40 milliards
d'euros en allégements de charges et
subventions aux entreprises pour
stimuler les embauches
l'exécutif estime que le compte n'y est
pas pourtant pierre gattaz s'est engagé
à favoriser la création d'un million
d'emplois n'est pas à qualifier
l'attitude de pierre gattaz j'ai
simplement à dire que dans pacte de
responsabilité il ya le mot
responsabilité
aujourd'hui il ya très peu d'accords de
branches qui sont signés c'est un échec
aujourd'hui c'est aussi le sien la lune
de miel entre le patronat le
gouvernement semble terminée ovationnée
lors de la dernière université d'été du
medef
manuel valls est montré particulièrement
sévère à l'encontre du patronat cet
après midi à l'assemblée nationale
chacun doit être à la hauteur de ses
responsabilités et je le dis notamment
aux dirigeants du patronat
un certain nombre de propositions de
provocation de propos aujourd'hui ne
sont pas à la hauteur de cette
responsabilité
prise en étau les représentants des
entreprises demandent du temps pour
mettre en application les différents
aspects du pacte votée en juillet tout
en critiquant les difficultés de
certaines mesures comme le conte
pénibilité nous fondons beaucoup
d'espoirs sur ce pacte de responsabilité
nous l'avons même dit au moment où ça a
été mise en place
cette formulation de dire que c'est un
échec c'est totalement irresponsable
irresponsable pour les entreprises qui
ont besoin de confiance
irresponsable pour le pays qui a besoin
de ce pack un an après le lancement en
grande pompe par françois hollande le
pacte de responsabilité peine à
s'installer
des accords ont été signés dans
seulement deux branches professionnelles
sur la cinquantaine que compte le pays
les entreprises c'est terminé d'ailleurs
c'est à dire pas longtemps
contre moi c'est fini on change tout au
fond c'est le kazakh on tourne casaque
enfin qu'à écouter je regarde cette
semaine monsieur valls est en train de
revenir vers la gauche de la gauche
c'est un retour aux sources on revient
vers le parti socialiste classique
traditionnelle bref on défait tout ce
que l'on a fait hier il y avait un
sentiment une envie oui je me suis
abstenu sur le pacte de responsabilité
parce que je pensais que c'était un
grand rendez vous de la france encore en
banque et le gouvernement a encore raté
le coche et pourquoi la droite ne l'a
pas fait c'est quand même de l'argent
qui est mis sur la table ce n'est pas
rien mais là je me sens que je me suis
abstenu il ça signifie qu' il y avait
des choses qui me gênait pourquoi parce
que les perspectives économiques à moyen
terme était réaliste je ne peux pas
voter pour un projet de loi qui s'appuie
sur des perspectives économiques
irréalistes
en revanche il y avait des vraies une
vraie volonté je le redis il y avait de
l'argent qui était mis sur la table et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me suis
abstenu quel est le bilan
six mois après c'est cataclysmique le
gouvernement rappelle comment
l'expliquer parce que le gouvernement
est écartelé entre sa droite et sa
gauche entre la droite de la gauche qui
aujourd'hui veut conduire une politique
sociale démocrate et la gauche de la
gauche qui n'en veut pas
qui veut rester sur les vieilles
l'ancien socialiste et c'est la raison
pour laquelle sans majorité ce
gouvernement ne peut pas faire croire et
perçoivent hollande
non c'est le gouvernement mais c'est
françois hollande lui même bien sûr
manuel valls il a envie d'avancer il a
envie de réformer mais tant qu'il n'y
aura pas de majorité cohérente de toute
façon le gouvernement ne pourra pas
avancer manuel valls ne pourra pas
travailler et françois hollande ne
pourra pas avoir un capteur le
gouvernement n'a pas les moyens
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le gouvernement
est en place le gouvernement ni françois
hollande ont les moyens ils n'ont plus
de majorité mais sinon plus de majorité
c'est leur faute pourquoi c'est leur
parce qu'elle est ce qu ils ont
été clairs lors de 2012 du projet
présidentiel du parti socialiste non ils
n'ont pas été claires
c'était un projet qui était fondée sur
la finance est mon ennemi or aujourd'hui
qui est qui et le ministre
l'économie et des finances c'est un
ancien de la finance qui était l'ennemi
d'hier
ça signifie quoi ça signifie que à la
fois dans le gouvernement on veut
changer la façon de faire mais en même
temps on a fait élire une majorité sur
un programme qui n'a rien à voir avec la
volonté aujourd'hui c'était car
tellement fait qu'il n'ya plus de
majorité pour soutenir ni le
gouvernement les présidents al-hilal
macron puisque vous faites référence à
lui il a lui même reconnu que ce pacte
doit exister un échec est ce que là il
fait une erreur politique en disant ça
non moi il dit la vérité c'est déjà bien
la seule chose c'est que j'aurais
préféré qu'il reconnaisse sa propre
responsabilité celle de son gouvernement
plutôt que de fustiger les patrons sur
le thème de c'est leur faute
le pacte ne marche pas parce que c'est
leur faute non moi je ne l'acceptent pas
lorsque quelque chose ne marche pas il
faut aussi prendre sa part de
responsabilité
la loi des manuels macro sur la
croissance arrive la semaine prochaine à
l'assemblée nationale
qu'est ce qu'on ferait j'ai d'abord
regardé le contenu et puis je vais voir
comment est ce que le nez mais c'est
comme pour récupérer leur travail de
confection et vente et s'associer
beaucoup de choses voilà il ya beaucoup
de faire revenir beaucoup jours nous
allons nous allons regarder chacune des
mesures nous allons les discuter mais il
lorsque j'observe sur la loi de finance
comment est-ce que le gouvernement était
en retrait de toutes les avancées qui
ont été proposés par l'opposition
lorsque j'observe que sur cette
proposition de résolution totalement
politicienne sur la place et palestine
le gouvernement la majorité n'a jamais
été capable de faire une avancée vers
l'opposition
j'observe aujourd'hui que cette majorité
totalement partie dans le sectarisme
c'est ce qui me fait peur c'est ce qui
m'inquiète c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi je les appelle pour davantage
d'ouverture et davantage de discussions
alors revenons jérôme chartier sur les
députés qui ont donc donné leur feu vert
à la reconnaissance d'un état
palestinien c'était mardi la résolution
socialiste a été adopté avec 339 voix
pour 151 contre une majorité de députés
ump aient eu délit s'est opposé au texte
retour en séance
avec jean-baptiste daoulas pour 339
entre 151 une résolution votée largement
sous le regard de journalistes venus du
monde entier
c'est donc officiel l'assemblée
nationale invite le gouvernement à
reconnaître l'état palestinien
le gouvernement français peut
reconnaître bilatéralement l'état de
palestine est d'ailleurs ensuite ce que
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
peut reconnaître l'état palestinien
donc il suffit même pas il suffit
certainement pas d'une résolution du
parlement il se fait même pas d'une
reconnaissance unilatérale du
gouvernement français il faut un vote du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies la
résolution votée par les députés n'est
pas contraignante elle n'oblige en rien
le gouvernement à reconnaître l'état
palestinien
d'ailleurs il n'y avait qu'un secrétaire
d'état harlem désir dans l'hémicycle au
moment du vote
cette résolution n'engage pas le
gouvernement mais je crois qu'il faut
l'entendre comme un appel au retour à la
table des négociations qui est adressé à
l'ensemble des belligérants et à la
communauté internationale comme cela
était le cas d'ailleurs dans d'autres
parlements de pays de l'union européenne
massivement l'opposition a voté contre
la résolution dénonçant une opération de
communication des socialistes votre
résolution et vous le savez elle est
juridiquement nul
elle va mettre de l'huile sur le feu
dans une région du monde qui n'en a pas
besoin et ne résoudra rien elle risque
au contraire d'opposer ici en france des
français entre eux un autre vote très
symbolique est prévue en décembre
le parlement européen doit lui aussi se
prononcer sur la reconnaissance de la
palestine
jérôme chartier est ce que pour vous
c'était le bon moment pour voter cette
résolution au parlement
c'était ni le moment ni la bonne façon
de le faire
j'ajoute que s'il ya sa demande le
député vous l'avez dit chloé contre il
ya aussi des députés qui ont refusé de
participer au vote ils sont 71 ont fait
partie françois fillon valérie pécresse
d'autres pourquoi parce que nous ne
voulions pas voté contre le principe de
reconnaissance de la palestine
en revanche si on décide de reconnaître
la palestine comme nous
souhaitons il faut que le hamas accepte
de reconnaître aussi l'état d'israël
l'un sans l'autre un monde politique
la la c'est un vote pour protéger
l'avenir de la résolution du conflit
israélo palestinien
voilà la raison pour laquelle nous avons
décidé de ne pas participer au vote
c'était une non participation politique
engagée pour faire en sorte que
l'initiative puisse demeurer
l'initiative c'est celle de l'exécutif
s'est pas seulement l'exécutif français
c'est l'exécutif des principales nations
du monde qui doivent s'engager fortement
pour résoudre le conflit israélo
palestinien
le débat était plutôt quand même dans
d'autres pays européens je pense à
l'angleterre gâteau la belgique
également où ça a l'air d'être assez
simple à régler comme c'était il y a
qu'en france où à l'assemblée comme au
sénat on le voit il ya autant de débats
sur cette question pourquoi parce que le
régime politique est différent c'est à
dire le pré le premier ministre ou en
grande-bretagne dépend de sa majorité
parlementaire
en l'occurrence en france le premier
ministre est nommé par le président de
la république on dit pas exactement dans
le même région ça veut dire qu'au fond
alors annoncé l'initiative l'initiative
politique appartient à l'exécutif à
partie en présidant la position et ce
n'est pas la responsabilité de parlement
que de s'engager dans l'initiative
diplomatique
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
proposition de résolution n'avait pas
lieu d'être
en l'occurrence c'est une erreur c'est
une erreur non seulement pour la
résolution de ce conflit israël aux
palestiniens
sur le plan diplomatique mais également
c'est une erreur par rapport aux
tensions que l'on observe depuis
quelques mois en france
moi je suis député de sarcelles je suis
donc le député qui a été témoin des
événements à sarcelles
à la fin du mois de juillet d'un simple
à attiser les tensions kojima lula je ne
l'avais jamais vu en quinze ans de
responsabilités de député de sarcelles à
sarcelles ça signifie que aujourd'hui la
tension entre les communautés réelle
elle est très forte faire un vote comme
ça c'est simplement remettre de l'huile
sur le feu c'est la raison pour laquelle
je n'ai pas participé au vote aussi et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je dénonce
cette initiative en parlant des
initiatives politicienne on a compris
votre position en avant ce mercredi
l'actualité très politique on ouvre la
page ump
c'était donc l'événement politique de la
semaine l'élection de nicolas sarkozy à
la tête de l'ump les choses n'ont pas
traîné à peine élu déjà en consultations
tous azimuts premiers reçus bruno le
maire l'homme qui a fait 29 % objectif
former une nouvelle équipe et rassembler
la famille politique ump qui
développerait talent et de leur groupe à
l'assemblée nationale ça nous a raconté
par germain andrieu et les à berthelot
mais c'est une opération séduction sous
haute surveillance médiatique nicolas
sarkozy invité spécial à la réunion de
groupe des députés ump
avec un seul objectif le rassemblement
une première poignée de main pour bruno
le maire sans oublier les fillonnistes
ou encore jean françois copé nicolas
sarkozy justifie son retour par la
gravité de la situation est selon ses
propres mots demande que l'accès soit
trouvé pour mettre un terme à la haine
au sein du parti
à la sortie un seul mot d'ordre
officiellement l'unité autorités
rassemblement unités sont les trois mots
qui me paraissent le mieux résumé cette
rencontre et puis cette rencontre et
nous a fait du bien un petit débat
questions en questions/réponses avec
avec les parlementaires
applaudi à plusieurs reprises je crois
que tout le monde était heureux d'avoir
la famille rassemblée unie nous sommes
tous derrière ce président et il faut
abandonner les chapelles les clans et
les étiquettes
mais la partie reste difficile les
soutiens sont partagés entre françois
fillon
bruno le maire nicolas sarkozy ou encore
alain juppé pour le moment aucun
organigramme définitif mais quelques
postes clés frédéric péchenard pour la
direction générale de l'ump daniel
fasquelle pourrait être trésorier et
s'il concret d'ouverture thierry solère
sera chargé d'organiser les primaires en
moi j'ai été chargé sur proposition de
bruno le maire par nicolas sarkozy
l'organisation de ce comité de primaire
avec l'ensemble des représentants des
différents candidats déjà déclarés qui
seront bien sûr associer pleinement à
son organisation
c'est un exercice très nouveau pour la
droite française que de faire cela et
voilà moi je vais mettre au travail avec
rigueur
transparence pour que ça se passe
vraiment bien le moment venu en
attendant les consultations se
poursuivent après françois fillon ce
sera au tour d'alain juppé de rencontrer
nicolas sarkozy avant la tenue d'un
bureau politique au siège du parti est
l'occasion de compléter la future
organisation de l'ump par une tape dans
le dos -maux gentil pour tout le monde
m'a fait avancer lui rassembleur c'est
lui le président n'est a été élu c'est
une élection démocratique et en
l'occurrence s'il ya une élection
démocratique c'est parce que françois
fillon a tout fait pour que cette
élection ait lieu avec le triumvirat
avec son pierre raffarin avec alain
juppé donc aujourd'hui on a un président
démocratiquement élu
ce qui permet de relancer ump qui paie
c'est vrai encalminé depuis deux ans en
larmes aux yeux quand ça ne fonctionnait
pas vous étiez dans la salle vous avez
entendu certainement cette phrase stop
oen qui divise notre camp s'est adressé
à qui ça alors il se trouve que je n'ai
pas arrivé au bout il ya pas quand c'est
comme ça je suis arrivé juste après donc
je pense que ça s'adressait à tout le
monde aux amis nicolas sarkozy à ceux
qui se sont opposés à ses amis bref à
tout le monde je pense qu'il a raison il
faut mettre fin au n 10 r il faut
dépasser ces tensions il faut se dire
que aujourd'hui la campagne est terminée
la campagne pour la présidence de l'ump
en l'occurrence et non pas ce qu'il faut
et ce que frau c'est vrai dans une
vision de rassemblement il dans une
démarche de rassemblement et quand tous
d'accord et qu'en pensent les militants
les sympathisants l'opinion c'est la
question qu'on pose maintenant c'est
notre zoom de la semaine
yves marie cann nous a rejoint sur le
plateau de parlement hebdo bonjour je
vous êtes directeur général délégué en
charge de l'opinion au csa je vois que
vous avez beaucoup de petits de petits
graphiques qui sont intéressants donc
que disent ces graphiques est ce que
nicolas sarkozy sent renforcé de sa
nouvelle stature de chef de l'ump quand
et où en est son image m'a écoutée en
tout cas la victoire de nicolas sarkozy
est pour le moins incontesté ce qui déjà
change beaucoup de ce qui s'est passé il
ya deux ans à lui à l'ump
ceci étant dit lorsqu'on regarde les
dynamiques du côté de l'opinion publique
on s'aperçoit que il n'ya pas finalement
de dynamique positive qui s'est
enclenchée pour nicolas effectivement
par rapport à ce qu'on pouvoir pour
d'autres personnalités deux chiffres en
septembre avant sa déclaration de
candidature à la présidence de l'ump 39%
des français déclaraient avoir une image
positive de nicolas sarkozy dans l'
enquête que nous avons réalisés en tout
début de semaine après son élection la
présidence ump
il est à 32 % donc nicolas sarkozy en
trois mois a perdu sept points de bonnes
opinions auprès de la population
française on voit bien combien
finalement le retour sur le devant de la
scène politique et le retour par la case
- l'ancien chef de l'état est
particulièrement délicat c'est un petit
mot sur ce chiffre
quand même ça vous surprend premier de
françois fillon vous êtes surpris par
cette baisse de popularité de nicolas
sarkozy en tout cas l'image
non mais j'ai observé cette baisse
depuis plusieurs mois pour une raison
très simple c'est que lorsqu'on s'engage
à nouveau dans la vie politique active
on passe à la moulinette des sondages
donc c'est quelque chose qui est assez
classique on a pu observer pour
l'ensemble des responsables politiques
et puis après il ya des tensions les
français de droite n'aime pas les
tensions c'est vrai mais sa frappe tout
le monde je vais très bon soin fillon le
daf enfants soient fiers aussi sa frappe
ras alain juppé le moment venu mais ce
qui est normal
une fois que l'on s'engage dans à la une
réels c'est-à-dire en l'occurence que
l'on commença à prendre des positions
extrêmement forte que l'on s'engage dans
une démarche comme celle du chemin qui
conduit aux primaires pour la
présidentielle
eh bien on passe à la mountain des
sondages ça arrivera à chacun un numéro
où effectivement enfin alain juppé est
très haut depuis de nombreux mois mais
c'est vrai qu'il continue à progresser
dans l'est dans les enquêtes d'opinion
sur le mois de décembre il est à 56%
d'opinions positives dans notre
baromètre csa avec les échos déjà c'est
la seule personnalité parmi la vingtaine
que l'on teste qui est au dessus de la
barre des 50% et alain juppé en l'espace
de 2-3 mois quand même gagné 7 % de
bonnes opinions et françois fillon et
françois fillon et c'est assez cyclique
en fait pour eux pour françois fillon
qui est avec nicolas sarkozy mais là il
y a deux personnalités politiques baisse
ce mois ci notre baromètre c'est nicolas
sarkozy et françois fillon
franchement ce que françois fillon
payent beaucoup la polémique qui l'a
concerné il ya quelques semaines autour
du fameux déjeuner de juillet puisqu'on
voit que s'il perd 4 points auprès de
l'ensemble des français françois puis
free françois fillon perd surtout 11
points auprès des sympathisants de
droite l'envoi ya quand même quelque
chose qui s'installe et en tout cas un
petit doute qui s'installe dans l'esprit
des sympathisants de droite aussi votre
vous avez des doutes concernant françois
fillon moi je n'ai aucun doute mais oui
je comprends ces chiffres puisque je me
mets à la place des français qui n'ont
pas l'information que celle qui ne
regarde pas cette affaire avec toute la
toute toute la finesse que que avec
laquelle je la regarde pour des
questions de temps tout simplement et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
donnerai mon départ je demande et
j'espère que le procès aura lieu le plus
rapidement possible de telle sorte que
françois fillon soit lavé de tout doute
qu'il retrouve auprès de tous les
français l'honnêteté qui le caractérise
en parlant de des fillonistes au sein du
nouvel organigramme ump qui est en train
de se mettre en place et ce que vous
avez obtenez vous des garanties que vous
serez bien représentées notamment dans
les instances exécutives circuit dont
j'ai le sentiment que nicolas sarkozy
évolué
marquer c'est cette image de
rassemblement de l'ump en l'occurrence
je sais que isabelle le callennec qui
est le député très engagé auprès de
françois fillon va être la nouvelle
porte parole de la formation politique
je m'en réjouis personnellement et je
pense que c'est un bon choix en
l'occurrence isabelle est une fille de
très grande qualité en l'occurrence
c'est quelqu'un qui qui est très proche
très proche de moi je veux revenir un
petit peu sur ce déjeuner avec il ya eu
entre françois fillon et nicolas sarkozy
s'étaient mardi se sont à nouveau
rencontrés on l'a vu cette image
notamment dans des zones et c'était une
rencontre devenait viendra d'une
information vous nous donnez et dans
l'après midi on a appris que nicolas
sarkozy fait un chèque finalement de
3600 360000 615 euros une somme
notamment pour le parti avait déboursé à
l'époque pour la campagne de 2012 pour
les rejet des comptes de campagne
c'est ce que vous souhaitiez c'est bien
qu'il ait fait ça il fait une pause et
que rien oui mais que rien à dire à
nicolas sarkozy demain je n'ai rien à
dire de mal contre nicolas sarkozy
je suis moi même engagé dans une
démarche de rassemblement
chacun aujourd'hui souhaitent cette
démarche tous les militants les
adhérents de l'ump souhaite cette
démarche on le souhaite tous on a besoin
aujourd'hui d'une formation politique
rassemblée ça ne veut pas dire que l'on
ne se prépare pas chacun pour la
première pour la présidentielle mais je
le dis chaque chose en son temps
aujourd'hui il y à des enjeux face à
nous il y a aussi le fait de porter le
fer contre la majorité c'est très
important dans la mesure où les français
attendent cela les français sont de plus
en plus nombreux à rejeter cette
majorité les français souhaitent que
l'opposition soient mobilisés soit forte
et en l'occurrence - germi d'être l'un
des acteurs de cette mobilisation de
l'opposition très forte contre le
gouvernement américain est ce que vous
pensez que les français et notamment les
sympathisants ump encore la culture du
chef
oui bien sûr on pourrait bien d'ailleurs
que
les sympathisants ump restent très
nostalgique à l'égard de nicolas sarkozy
si nicolas sarkozy et étant plutôt en
baisse au sein de l'opinion publique
quand ils conservent ils à conserver et
à toujours aujourd'hui un capital de
sympathie extrêmement fort voire même
qui relève de la nostalgie effectivement
extrêmement forte par rapport à sa
présidence et donc ce que l'on même si
on voit par contre en revanche que l'on
voit s'installer aujourd'hui auprès des
sympathisants ump
c'est qu'il y à une sorte d'alternative
quand même qui se fait jour et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne voyait pas qu'on
a pas vu au cours des dernière des dix
dernières années et cette alternative
dans l'esprit d'un certain de
sympathisants c'est alain juppé qui
selon vous walter du moment où et
retrouvera dans les îles ses mécaniques
de toutes façons ça n'a rien à voir avec
la bourse à la beauté n'est pas rentré
non mais on le voit maintenant l'entente
tous les jours quasiment bah écoutez
vous n'entendez pas tous les jours est
observée à la loi mais mes amis sont là
mais on l'entend régulièrement mais les
mêmes chances bien pourtant bien qui
parce qu'au moment où vous allez à la
rencontre des français où vous vous
positionnez sur l'ensemble des sujets
c'est à dire que vous ne vous ne restez
plus en retrait pour rentrer vraiment
sur les sujets vous allez excuse comme
comme on le dit clivé c'est à dire que
vous allez à la fois conforté des
partisans mais en même temps créer des
mécontentements et les mécontentements
on voulait retrouver mécaniquement dans
les sondages voilà nicolas sarkozy
quelqu'un qui clivent régulièrement
depuis maintenant deux ans françois
fillon prend des positions extrêmement
forte
il produit des idées très régulièrement
et en l'occurrence et y décrivent c'est
naturel puisque dès lors que vous
proposer quelque chose que vous soutenez
une démarche et bien vous avez des
partisans et vous avez des opposants une
sortie grâce ion 2 millions de français
ayant récemment fait exactement il sait
et c'est cela la vie politique la vie
politique c'est d'accepter de faire des
mécontents de mise en même temps comment
est-ce qu'on avance si on ne met pas sur
la table des propositions comment est ce
qu'on fait progresser un pays si on ne
dit pas clairement au pays la voie dans
laquelle on souhaite
le voir s'engager voilà ça c'est
l'engagement du politique un mot quand
même sur la ligne du parti politique de
votre parti et l'ump le secrétaire
général c'est le révoquer numéro 2 et
numéro 3 n'a pas bien compris et
nathalie kosciusko morizet nous leurs
deux numéro 3 n'a pas bien compris dont
je vais vous rassurer en délire c'est
très simple il ya deux numéros deux
voiliers comme ça c'est pratique ça
permet de la vie d'enfer logique et
d'être dans cette logique totalement
différente écoutez y aura une expression
libre et moi j'aime bien cette liberté
d'expression j'en suis non seulement
l'un des partisans des acteurs mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui un mouvement et
plurielle ça signifie quoi ça signifie
que chacun peut donner son point de vue
après il faut définir une ligne
mais la ligne ça ce débat ça se définit
pas par principe dans le cénacle de
trois personnes et ce qui me rassure
c'est de voir que puisqu'il y a deux
numéros 2 avec deux lignes un peu
différente entre l'un et l'autre
c'est la certitude que la ligne de l'ump
sera véritablement débattues
moi j'ai besoin dans ce débat j'ai
besoin de ce débat d'idées et je ne suis
pas le seul
les adhérents de l'ump ont besoin de ce
débat d'idées oui je vais je vais aller
le plus clair je lui avais plus loin est
ce que vous croyez aujourd'hui que dans
une formation politique
la ligne doit se décider entre trois
personnes la réponse est non
est ce que vous pensez cela non et bien
voilà et bien voilà je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ça ça pour moi c'est le
parti shas d'hier ça s'est terminé
la ligne c'est le chef cobol-it le
président qui fait en sorte d'organiser
le débat et du débat vous tirer une
ligne vous fait tranché par exemple j'ai
entendu nicolas sarkozy lancé l'idée que
je trouve bonne
voyez je suis très élogieux à l'égard de
nicolas sarkozy vous pouvez l'observer
que je trouve même qui de faire trancher
par tous les adhérents de l'ump par
référendum un sujet au mois de janvier
prochain
je ne connais pas le sujet je ne suis
pas dans le secret des dieux mais le
principe selon lequel on va pouvoir
débattre de sujets puis ensuite on va le
faire trancher par un vote
oui là cela me plaît et ce qu'ils
auraient vécu ce qui aurait déplu c'est
d'avoir une ligne qui se définit
seulement au sommet et qui s'applique
pour chacun d'entre nous et ça c'est
plutôt voir
alors on va interroger yves marie cann
rapidement sur un sondage csa assez
édifiant si des élections législatives
devaient avoir lieu aujourd'hui
la gauche serait laminée expliquez-nous
effectivement nous avons réalisé avec le
figaro une mesure du rapport de force
politique dans la perspective
d'éventuelles élections législatives un
professeur noir et iam et à partir de ce
rapport de force nous avons établi une
projection en termes de composites de
quelle serait la composition de
l'assemblée nationale et c'est vrai
qu'on voit qu'aujourd'hui alors que
l'exécutif pâti d'un niveau record
d'impopularité
et bien c'est tout ceci aurait des
répercussions électorales extrêmement
forte
par contre si on met en avant un autre
scrutin et aux scrutins proportionnels
notamment intégral là on voit que tout
le monde baisse mais que le parti
socialiste s'en sort à peu près on peut
imaginer que françois hollande et fait
il des ventes est en tout cas là la
proportionnelle
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle et est présente dans le
programme de françois hollande il me
semble même d'ailleurs que nicolas
sarkozy s'est rallié à un moment ou un
autre à 7 à cette idée et c'est vrai
qu'on voit bien que l'antre le scrutin
uninominal majoritaire à deux tours et
le scrutin pour port-au-prince
proportionnelle en termes de répartition
des sièges au sein de l'assemblée
nationale pour un même rapport de force
poétique de départ effectivement
franchement il ya des écarts qui sont
extrêmement émotionnelles
we do rosario première dans la
proportionnelle tout est dans la dose
alors c'est quoi la 12c la motive c'est
un car c'est un tir c'est quoi la limite
100 parlementaires élus à la
proportionnelle je suis d'accord ce que
je veux c'est pouvoir fait si la
deuxième remarque former une majorité
une l'assemblée nationale c'est fait
pour former une majorité c'est pas fait
pour qu'il y ait une représentativité
parfaite des sensibilités français si on
n'a pas de majorité on ne peut pas
gouverner
merci américaine d'avoir été sur ce
plateau pour apporter votre éclairage on
passe à jeudi on parle du parti
socialiste qui prépare doucement mais
sûrement son congrès
ils étaient sur le terrain pour prendre
le pouls des militants socialistes
jean-christophe cambadélis a terminé
trois mois de marathon pour clore ces
états généraux du ps jean baptiste
daoulas l'a suivi à rennes reportage
jean christophe cambadélis termine trois
mois de marathon à la rencontre des
militants des états généraux pour
redéfinir l'identité des socialistes
5600 contributions ont été déposés avec
l arrivée une charte d'une dizaine de
pages
ces états généraux on n'en parle pas
beaucoup dans la presse nationale
mais c'est un succès des états généraux
pour écouter des militants parfois
déboussolés par la politique du
gouvernement
comme ce militant qui n'a toujours pas
digéré les baisses d'impôts pour les
entreprises
on peut encourager des entreprises
celles qui investissent qui développe
qui font de la recherche fondamentale
laon faut aider ces entreprises à mais
si on donne des chèques en blanc pour
des entreprises juste pour avoir des
dividendes supplémentaires c'est pas bon
de ma ferme conti le conseil
constitionnel
dix nations entre les entreprises
mais on doit trouver des moyens du bord
investissent à rawdon
là où il y en a vraiment besoin pour les
entreprises donner la parole aux
militants 100 m pour autant en danger le
gouvernement
un équilibre compliqué à l'arrivée la
charte est jugée trop libérale par les
courants de la gauche
ils ne voteront pas le texte disons qu'à
partir du moment où on est au pouvoir
c'est un petit peu étrange de nous
demander casque préfet si on était au
pouvoir dans la charte on interroge à
aucun moment ce que ce que fait le
gouvernement
c'est plutôt une charte qui va
d'ailleurs dans le sens de ce qui se
passe au gouvernement les états généraux
n'auront donc pas été le grand moment
d'unité que voulait la direction du ps
tous les courants du parti ont déjà les
yeux rivés vers le congrès de juin 2015
avec pour l'ailé gauche
l'espoir de mettre le gouvernement en
minorité
est ce que pour vous le parti socialiste
a raison de donner la parole à ses
militants avec cette charte
ces états généraux j'ai beaucoup aimé la
réaction de la jeune fille qui dit mais
c'est bien qu'on me demande ce qu'on le
ferait si on était au pouvoir sachant
qu'on est au pouvoir
oui c'est tout le problème des
socialistes alors rendez vous compte ils
vont interroger leurs militants pour
savoir ce qu'ils devraient faire s'il
était aux responsabilités sauf qu'ils y
sont déjà depuis deux ans ça veut dire
qu'ils sont complètement perdus
ça veut dire qu'il ya non seulement je
l'avais dit pour vous avez un boulevard
mais aujourd'hui l'opposition affichée
mais non mais on n'a pas profité pendant
deux ans pourquoi parce que nous ne
nions pas un président légitimement élu
à la tête de l'ump voilà on se dit toute
la vérité
maintenant c'est le coeur pourquoi
est-ce que je m'en félicite parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va pouvoir repartir du
bon pied et dans une vision de
rassemblement on va pouvoir être
offensive de nouveau et par conséquent
être audible être lisible et marquer
cette opposition responsable qui doit
nous caractérise et voilà la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui je me satisfait de
cette élection démocratique et en même
temps j'observe que les socialistes
oui c'est vrai sont encalminés toujours
pour la même raison parce que ils n'ont
pas résolu lors écartèlement eu
d'illogique de 2012
tant qu'ils n'arriveront pas le résoudre
de toute façon nous n'arrivons pas eu à
gouverner je vais peut-être entendu
michel rocard cette semaine dans une
tribune dans le monde qui a dit la
droite a tout le temps changeait de nom
de son parti est aujourd'hui ne savent
plus raconter une histoire c'est vrai
nom c'est pareil geste inutile de
changer non encore écouter on verra bien
nous avons bien joué
pour maintenir le nom ump parce que
j'estime que le nom me paie c'est une
histoire justement
et quelle est cette histoire c'est
l'histoire du rassemblement de toutes
les sensibilités de la droite au sein
d'une seule et même famille politique
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
histoire qui date de 12 ans seulement
c'est une histoire qui est assez jeunes
ump
encore un long avenir grand talent moi
je veux garder le nom de mp le nom ump
ça correspond à quelque chose ça
correspond à la fin de la guerre des
partis de droite et je veux que ce nom
mp puis surtout permettre de porter la
famille politique de droite encore sur
un très long à venir je suis certain
qu'on va pouvoir l'obtenir et je suis
même certain que nicolas sarkozy est en
train de réfléchir à l'opportunité de
changer de nom alors on va parler un peu
de la france dans le monde est cette
nouvelle les chinois qui débarque en
force sur le tarmac de toulouse blagnac
puisque un consortium a racheté une
partie de l'aéroport
ce n'est qu'une partie mais mais mais
tout de même ces départs qui sont
détenues par par des chinois est ce que
cette présence chinoise dans un secteur
français stratégie que vous vous
inquiète
vous vous dites c'est une bonne nouvelle
ce que j'observe d'abord c'est que c'est
une participation qui est minoritaire
c'est à dire que la majorité n'est pas
détenu par les chinois c'est une
minorité qui de tenue et de deux choses
l'une soit décide soit on décide que la
france est ancré dans la mondialisation
que la france est une nation
exportatrice et dans ce cas là on
accepte le principe de la mondialisation
c'est à dire on accepte que les
entreprises françaises puissent avoir
des actionnaires minoritaires
qu'ils soient étrangers on accepte que
des concessions françaises comme par
exemple l'aéroport de toulouse puisse
avoir des participations minoritaires
étrangères et en l'occurrence ça permet
de voir la france comme une nation qui
est ouverte sur le monde une nation par
conséquent que l'on accepte d'accueillir
dans les autres pays parce que ça veut
dire quoi cet investissement ça veut
dire que lorsqu on ira voir les chinois
on leur dira nous aussi on peut prendre
des participations minoritaires parce
qu'on vous laisse les prendre dans notre
pays donc il ya forcément un principe de
réciprocité
si tel n'est pas le cas alors il faudra
que la change à lui que la france allons
voir si sa stratégie alors c'était la
france change de stratégie et en
l'occurrence il y aura peut-être des
mesures de rétorsion vis à vis de la
chine
nous n'en sommes pas là aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de croire que la chine
à aussi elle de son côté le souhait
d'offrir à la france des opportunités de
participation minoritaire dans des
situations de conseillers du roi de
nouvelles pour vous je pense que c'est
une opportunité que cette opportunité
peut être saisie par la france pour
pouvoir demander la réciprocité à la
chine emmanuel bach roddick ce n'est pas
une privatisation vous appelez ça
comment non ce n'est pas une
privatisation
cette privation privatisation c'est plus
de 50% en l'occurrence et même à plus de
50%
donc c'est une prise de participation
minoritaire on va passer aux puces de
l'hebdo on va pas c'est aussi ce qu'on
appelle les entretiens de royaumont
comme vous vous avez présidé en tout cas
pendant de nombreuses années c'est le
plus de l'hebdo vous avez relancé ses
entretiens de royaumont depuis 2003 va
essayer de prendre un petit peu de
hauteur ce sont des endroits où on
reconnaît en tout cas l'un des
principaux lieux de réflexion politique
qui rassemble des décideurs de tous
horizons
simon barbarie retrace un petit peu
l'historique de ces entretiens droit you
est ce que la france a une croissance
réussie
nous en parlerons entre chose
entretiennent royaumont impôts dette
publique croissance construire un
triangle vertueux voilà le thème
qu'annonçait jérôme chartier l'année
dernière et qui occupera tout le
week-end les participants des entretiens
de royaumont et qu'est ce que c'est au
fait ces entretiens de royaumont une
sorte de mini forum de davos mais chez
des moines à asnières sur oise dans
cette abbaye du xiiie siècle on voit
arriver tous les ans avec l'hiver des
hommes et des femmes politiques de
droite comme de gauche des grands
patrons ou encore des dirigeants
étrangers
du beau monde pour comme l'expliquent le
site internet débattre de la france et
de ce qu'elle sera demain
l'ambiance est à la convivialité même au
franc parler comme cette intervention
l'année dernière de l'ancien pdg de
total christophe de margerie
aujourd'hui disparu merde plus de loi
utilisons celles que nous avons à chaque
fois une nouvelle loi qui est
complètement contradictoire avec
l'ancien parfois le message exprimé et
plus concret plus politiques comme en
2012 lorsque françois fillon revenait
sur le fiasco des élections à lui m
je ne suis plus à me demander qui a
gagné ou qui a perdu et il ne m'apporte
plus de savoir à qui la faute si cette
élection a si mal tourné depuis le début
je dis que pour sortir de l'impasse
il faut redonner la parole aux adhérents
cette année les résultats des élections
à l'ump semble indiscutable déjà un
sujet en moins pour ses entretiens de
royaumont dit toute sa vérité on dit
toutes les vérités mais c'est vrai
j'avais chacun la sienne mais en même
temps c'est un endroit que je suis très
fier d'avoir relancé ses entretiens en
2003 c'est parti d'une idée c'est une
vraie histoire les entretient une
histoire d'amitié d'abord d'amis qui se
mettent autour de la table qui décide de
relancer à un endroit de réflexion
décoincer une réflexion mais c'est ce
que concrètement il ya des choses qui en
ressortent qui font avancer un petit peu
le pays ou pas ou alors on ne fait que
parler nom ne fait pas que parler vous
savez une idée politique ça une façon
d'être construit très particulière comme
on dit d'abord sa paire cole c'est à
dire ccmi quelque part en l'occurrence
aux entretiens de royaumont et puis
s'est diffusé dans toute l'audience il
ya 450 500 personnes qui viennent chaque
année aux entretiens à peu près 800 900
personnes qui passent parce que on ne
vient pas forcément et le samedi et le
dimanche
et donc toutes ces personnes diffuser
l'idée est ce qui fait qu'après cette
idée là revient comme une idée politique
de plusieurs façons d'y faire
concrètement ce que vous avez une idée
de quelque chose qui est sorti de ses
entretiens de royaumont un projet
initiative jean n'est pas une zone de 10
sur 10 ans dans des 1000cc là c'est pas
dans ses calculs mais ses disciples inde
c'est quand même façon c'est plein
d'initiatives c'est plein d'esprit
différentes c'est nous qui avons par
exemple lancé la réforme de l'isf n'est
pas en supprimant unicef dans le module
ans et pourquoi est ce qu'on a fait
parce qu'on a senti que c'était un
véritable frein à la croissance
française par exemple on a aussi mis
plein d'autres idées notamment l'an
dernier lorsqu'on a parlé de l'appui aux
pays émergents du fait que les pays
émergents avaient besoin d'une
croissance pour surtout réguler ce fait
de migros à tort que l'on observe que
personne ne peut freiner le pô le
phénomène migratoire sa phénomène monde
douche tous les pilotes dans tous les
pays amis nettoyer tous les pays mais
surtout vont surtout aujourd'hui trouver
le moyen de générer la croissance pour
leur propre population c'est ce qu'on a
dit l'an dernier et en l'occurrence
cette année on va trouver le moyen de
faire que les impôts que les dépenses
publiques ça sera surtout majeur à la
croissance voilà cette année et je ayant
des aliments sur les entretiens
je souhaite que je souhaite vraiment
dans les entretiens continue à rester
cet endroit oecuménique de débat c est
d'un seul moment de la frappe
merci à jérôme chartier d'avoir été
l'invité de parlement hebdo